we've got virtual reality we've got 3d
headsets do you see where I'm going with
this people porn yeah you know it was
gonna happen porn does somehow lead the
way for everything right it got VHS to
take over after film it got DVDs to come
after VHS and then it's leading the way
in digital video and now using oculus
rift
Samsung has and Samsung gear I should
say well the porn people are making 3d
reality porn let's take a look
setting the mood I could see what people
would be into this all right that I mean
this just seems like the next step of
everything right like we're gonna go
into that world with porn or without but
most likely porn is coming along the way
no pun intended
yeah I don't know seems pretty cool do
you want 3d immersive porn is that what
you want I would like a real human being
my old school Oh like Aaron Brown I like
to read and I like people
oh my god I'm from 1928 yeah where are
you from 3d oculus rift porn I'm good
yeah you know I mean I'm not I'm not a
prude like I'm not like opposed to for
him but just like for me like it doesn't
really do it for me like I am also
old-school and prefer a human being yeah
so do you guys think that's just a
male/female thing I mean men are just
not is much more visual this is amazing
yeah I mean yeah but as a general rule I
would guess that men yeah probably
watch far more porn than women I know I
would agree yeah I would agree yeah so
in general what do you think of the this
3d oculus rift you know we did a lot on
Google glass last year and then it just
sort of did
so I think there's this idea that people
like all this stuff and we just did a
segment on the Luna bed where you know
you're technology you're gonna lay in
bed and it's gonna test you and know
what you're up to
but I do think there's also this element
of resistance to all this stuff element
of resisting of resisting all the
technology like we like it looks cool
and then I think people put on Google
glass they're like I don't know about
this when they put on this thing and
they realize they have to wear a giant
headset to see porn and you're like
maybe no well it was like you're saying
when you're walking in New York and
everyone's got the selfie stick it's
like it looks really cool if you just
actually watch it happening yeah I mean
it's like you're kind of missing out on
the moment while you're because they're
too busy capturing the moment yeah to
watch it later on your phone or you know
so I don't know I just
everything is so extreme and kind of
goes back to that maybe her you know
where I know everybody thought it was a
brilliant film but I never personally
could totally buy into it so I'm like
he's in love with this thing that
doesn't really exist right isn't that
what love is it's something we can't
define very deep and powerful and
profound do you guys think that at some
point we're gonna get to the point where
the only reason that people are having
actual sex like intercourse sex is to
have babies like I think they're gonna
get this stuff to a point where it's so
good it's so going to all of our senses
whether whether you guys are into it or
not that it's gonna just they're gonna
learn through science how to get it to
hit all of our senses audio-visual
everything that really people are
eventually just going to have sex to
reproduce because all there are other
ways of getting off and fetishes and all
that it's all going to be provided
something about like physical
interaction with another person know
that technology won't ever be able to
replace yeah so I I don't
or will it though I mean that the next
step is it'll you'll be able to smell it
and you know like I mean that's where it
all that's a little weird I mean we were
just talking about whether or not robots
are gonna take over I mean pretty soon
we're just gonna be like the battery if
you will in the machine because we you
know we're laying in bed it knows our
sleep cycles we're pretty much you know
sleeping with them at this point using
the oculus rift yeah what is there left
to do on your own and wasn't that the
point of the matrix that we were just
batteries that humans and the batteries
for me
right are we doing it willingly that's
the interesting thing anyway are we in
the matrix right now do you want to
watch 3d porn do you have an oculus rift
and any other thoughts that you might
have let us know in the comments right
down below
[Music]